Hold on. Break. Possibly breaking news. Possibly breaking news.
Oh, I don't know if Destiny is still here. I'm being informed.
Okay. By putting AE on indefinite pause.
Apparently, apparently. Apparently.
I'm an empath. I know what's going on in people's minds. I'm
I've done two years of psychology. I can mind read people. I
know what's going on. I bet you everyone has autism because I'm
going to diagnose everyone because I took one abnormal psych
class. I'm the king of psychology.
The Dan logs are not bait. Okay. Dan can no longer afford to
be associated with somebody who solicits minors for sex and sex
trafficking. Okay. Somebody tries to sex traffic minors. Dan
cannot be associated with that. Okay. He barely dodged the Diddy
bullet. He cannot be associated with people like that. All
Oh. Uh, Auggie did a stream on all the Destiny stuff today. Okay.
>> Obviously, you know, if we're going to go all the way
back, there was a time where I was a fan of Destiny. I I actually
have met Destiny and >> Auggie doesn't like that people
are trying to say that he got brainwashed. Okay, it's actually
kind of [__] up when you think about it. Auggie's
been ahead of the game on on Destiny hatred. And Destiny comes
out and says that he got like brainwashed by people into disliking
Destiny.
Augie was a day one. He was an OG hater. Okay, he hated Destiny
before it was cool person with Flamingco of all people, right?
But I've observed his behavior over the years and I've just noticed
it become increasingly unhinged. And at this point, I I'm comfortable
saying he's like the most evil person on the internet. was right.
>> And one of the things that makes him the most evil is
just how willing he is to just lie about anyone that gives him
any amount of criticism. Like I've now been subjected to it.
>> Let's go. Yes, that is exactly right.
My god, where does this guy get his talking points? It's like
he It's like he can see into my mind. It's like I handed him
a list of talking points.
I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. Augie,
I'm just kidding. Auggie, I'm just kidding.
Oh, wait. There's also, hold on, I totally forgot. I saw this
earlier today. I checked Twitter for a little bit. Did Destiny
leak, did Lauren de Laguna like DM Destiny recently?
Sorry, that just struck me.
H,
bro, there's like a couple weird things that happened. Okay.
>> The DG propaganda tour. The way that he
>> No. No, they're not old, Kger. No, I'm not talking about
I'm talking about she just messaged him like yesterday and was
going off on him. That's what I'm
>> Is false information and propaganda against his enemies.
I've now experienced it and observed it firsthand and I now know
why this guy hasn't gone down uh you know years prior when he
should have, right? So yeah, he just stinks. There's a lot of
stuff to get into with Destiny and we've got a lot of fun stuff
to take a look at here. Destiny is going down. I love to see
it. There is no one on the internet that deserves to lose their
career probably more than this guy and only because he's legitimized
by the biggest morons on the
There's so many people that are still consider themselves DGers.
Isn't that crazy? Think about that for a second. There's people
that are loud and
supporters still even after this brand new information is dropped.
Round them up. It's crazy. Uh, Alex Tissy Fever. >> Round
him up. Round him up. I do like that his chat does spam TDD a
lot. The funny thing is is like
people acted like that log from Chudlo Logic was like a revelation.
Like, oh my god, this guy thinks like TDD. He's like totally
after Destiny. It's like, you didn't get that from the first
like two weeks of streams after the leaks dropped and or after
the Pixie video dropped and my stream title had TDD in it every
single day. You didn't get that part cuz I was pretty transparent
about it. I was pretty transparent about like, "Yeah, [__]
this guy." I didn't I didn't think I was like I wasn't hiding
that. I was on that was just on the surface the whole time. >> Get
weird replies. Just go through why they who they follow and it's
always Destiny and Dan. Yeah, exactly. Well, it's not even just
who they follow. It's who follows them. Every unhinged reply
I've gotten, I go to their account, Dan follows them.
And I got to be careful calling out Dan because I don't want
to, you know,
>> I don't want that smoke. >> Yeah, I should say
although Dan did threaten to dox me at one point. Uh, he did.
Okay. He didn't blackmail me like last night or something. Some
people, a couple people messaged me like, "Is Dan blackmailing
you like right now?" No, I was just saying that like the threat
of like Dan was transparently doxing anybody who crossed him.
The threat of Dan like there was no overt threat. He wasn't blackmailing
me. Um some people like made that leap for no reason which is
annoying cuz now I have to come out and say he didn't actually
like literally blackmail me. Um he did kind of blackmail me back
whatever with anything else stuff but you know I kind of did
the same to him as like I said turnabouts flip. Fair play there.
That's what he told you to say. Can you hear the tapping? The
Morse code. Can you hear the tap? The Morse code. The Morse code
is coming through to you guys. Okay. SOS. SOS. SOS. >> Let
just just to be clear. Okay. I'm a complete when it comes to
people like Dan. But uh holy, dude. Every time I get an unhinged
reply. Just follow Dan on Twitter and then check your replies.
Find an unhinged. >> What made you stop being scared of
him doxing you? Uh that basically there are attempts out on everybody
now. And if your opse obssec isn't tight. Listen, they haven't
got me yet. They're not getting me, okay?
and it's always followed by Dan. It's crazy to me. It's [__]
nuts. Dan follows three follower accounts. Yeah, the same thing.
You know who else does that [__] Harley Morenstein
from Epic Meal Time. And it's not that I get unhinged replies
from like Harley Morenstein fans, but like I' I think I've checked
probably like hundreds or thousands of accounts and Harley Morenstein's
always following them, too. It's weird,
>> but um yeah. >> God, I've just suddenly had like
brain blast of all the stuff I was thinking about today. I think
the caffeine's finally hitting me. Okay. Looking through my downloads
and forgot I downloaded this insane clip. Okay. All right. Insane
clip. Actually, insane clip coming up. >> When you're 19,
you're a little kid. Okay. Now, if you're 22, >> if you're
19, you might as well be 15. It's not an insane. Well, sorry.
It is a Dude, this guy actually floods the zone with insanity.
Okay, he legitimately floods the zone. We've all seen this clip,
but it is insane. It actually is an insane clip, right? But the
zone is so flooded with absolutely insane that you can't really
appreciate, right? You can't appreciate it at all.
Like, it is actually he is literally saying, "Yeah, I'm 19-year-old
might as well be 15 to me." A 19-year-old is not a kid to you.
Okay, I'm 29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15year-old to me.
It's all the same, dude. Don't give me this. Just because of
some legal age of consent, whatever. I have about as much in
common with like an 18year-old, 19year-old freshman in school
as I would a sophomore in high school. Reminder, he went to a
girl he thought was 18, 19, okay, that was possibly a minor to
give him advice about approaching Lauren Southern. All right.
How do I fix my relationship with Molina and Lauren Southern?
These these adult women, how do I do that? It's just so tough.
It's just so tough. >> Any type of inclination towards
any of those people is really weird. When you're 19 Wow.
Uh I don't know if that girl from the beginning was 16, but if
she was and then Rose and then
Okay. Uh, Molina was 18 when they started DMing, I believe. Oh,
boy. It's Kick's new AI automod. So, hold on. I turned this down
yesterday and it didn't do anything.
I think I think a couple people turned it down. It's like literally
off. The automod is literally off right now.
It's like as off as can possibly be right now.
So, I don't know what's going on. I don't know, man.
I don't know what to tell you.
>> Let's see here. What is going on? >> Okay. I'm
probably not going to watch the very beginning of the Auggie
segment. All right, I'm going to go
until until until
What is this? These are the Twitter DMs.
He watches a little Oh, this Willy Mack point was pretty good.
Okay, the Willy Mack point. Um,
Willy Mack. Maybe it wasn't. Maybe it wasn't. Let's see here.
Let's see. Oh, he's watching one of my clips. Okay, hold on.
Watch one of my clips.
Basically, Willie Mack was talking about like all that time ago.
Destiny's like, "Oh, yeah, she's 18. Oh, hold on. I'll find it.
I'll find it real quick because it's from it's from the Willie
Mack video, and it is Destiny saying like she was 18."
>> Solo messaged me sometime in the morning and said that
he was unhappy with how the coverage of the leaks had been so
far. He felt as though people weren't giving it enough attention,
so he was going to leak more from my logs with Rose if I didn't
allow him to come on my stream and speak with me. I don't exactly
remember what the message to me was as I >> I'll get to
it, Anemone. I'll get to it. We'll get to it. just woken up,
read it, and then responded briefly before going back to sleep.
The next time I checked my messages with him, everything had
been deleted. >> Luckily, I have the messages. The messages
are solar demanding. Destiny talked to him on stream or else
he's going to leak all the DMs and videos he shared with Rose.
He also threatens to release Rose's real age, saying, "You were
negligent in verifying her age even after you joked about her
looking so young that you would need her ID to make sure she
was really even." >> Okay, this is curious, right? Because
what Solo is saying is backed up by those DMs. Again, that doesn't
confirm the DM's legitimacy, obviously, right? But everyone from
the very beginning has always said like Destiny just never cared
about like verifying her
>> 18. The only other time I heard this allegation of Rose
being potentially underage is when I interviewed Kelly >> He
he tweeted like a bit over a week ago that the Rose girl was
an Only Fans girl. She's not. She never she >> uh he put
that lie out there, too. God damn it. Okay, I'm skipping forward
to wherever this next clip comes up. All Jay's talk leaked DMs
of Destiny last night. So this is Destiny talking on >> Oh,
see I intentionally did this to show the lower time stamp here,
the 525 one and then there's the 526 one, right? I intentionally
did this to make it so that um yeah, to make it so it was obvious
it reads bottom up. >> December of 202 reads it bottom
up. >> Why would he tread so lightly on this if he's 100%
on it? But if she was a legit minor, I'm probably done. I can
sweep and meme my way through basically anything. Even though
some of it is really like, think of how stupid this is, though.
Yeah, the 24th. He brings it up and then drops it like immediately.
November 24th at like 6. >> Come on, Auggie. Come on, dude.
>> So, Destiny doesn't even know. He's like, there could
be a possibility if she was a legit minor. I'm [__]
Right. So, he doesn't know.
>> This is fine. But, uh, it it does go the other way.
It's like I can sweep my way through basically anything, but
if she was a minor, I'm probably done. That's how it reads. >> But
he's totally comfortable sending and receiving
material from this person and to this person. So, this like just
outright confirms it to me that he was just, you know, >> well,
I presented on my stream, Dickers. I didn't present it for other
people, right? I presented it on my stream. I read it bottom
up and I was like, this is how you read it. But fortunately,
we took
without without adding the arrow. Okay. He was he's the plausible
he's the plausibly deni >> I'm just glad that you know
it seems like something in his community's response to him his
clear guilt with Pixie and and Cherry and all these other people
his clear response to guilt sorry their clear response to his
guilt has shown him that like he might not be done even if he
minor or sorry even if he traded nudes with a minor traded videos
with a minor he might not be done before he thought he'd be done
now he's been awoken to the truth okay that his audience doesn't
care what he does that he can be as psychotic as possible And
it doesn't matter,
right? Doesn't matter at all. He'll do whatever the [__]
he wants. Oh, what? The fact that it took you 6 months to even
show this log is so pathetic and weak.
Yourself in a video game, but not in a video game, but also in
a video game cuz we're trying to be >> Deniable pedophile,
right? >> Um, actually, um,
it's really weak to not have linked this log earlier. Okay, [__]
where it's like if she says she's 17, he's not going to touch
that, >> Go ahead. Uh, explain how or why, Ammon. Go ahead.
>> But if she says she's 18 and that looks to be [__]
he'll still engage anyway. And then after the fact, he can always
sweep it up as like, well, I was the victim. She told me she
lied about her age.
>> And it's like, >> I talked about it like immediately.
Uh, I didn't I didn't ask you to ask me for an explanation. I
said, explain what
>> Bro, sure. She might have lied about her age, but think
that doesn't mean that you just had to engage in uh in conversations
with her. You didn't have to send her your friend's non-consensual
sex tape and and receive
Cam from her. You didn't have to do that.
You were suspicious from the start. And >> I'm explaining
to you what part of not showing this log, but saying that it
exists and saying it verbatim makes you a coward. Go ahead. last
chance to actually answer the question. >> Even after it's
exposed years later, you don't even you can't even confidently
say that she was overage. You tell Jay- Sock in private, you're
like, "Uh, if she was a kid, I'm fucked."
Implying that you don't even know at this moment, at this time,
you didn't know. But again, what's the excuse now? It's like,
"Oh, well, she lied." It's not good enough. There's plenty of
situations, yes, where like, you know, girls will go above and
beyond, right, to sort of set people up and lie about their age.
Of course, I'm not saying there's no times where it's like a
girl lies about her age and then the other guy like like the
guy there. You can't be a V. >> Wait, I don't think I posted
this log ages ago. Honestly, I just wanted to export with something
else, but uh
I couldn't for
uh I can't I can't I wanted to do like a different export and
I never got a chance to >> this situation is what I'm saying.
Right. In this particular instance though, I'm not buying it.
This is like a level of >> but realistically I said it
existed like a long time ago.
>> Yeah. negligence. That's like James Charles tier or
beyond in my opinion. Like yeah, James Charles, same thing, right?
Sure, people lied about their age to James Charles, right? But
we still pretty much all walked away from that whole situation
thinking that he was a piece of just for how often he was getting
himself involved in situations with minors where he just was
being reckless and not checking their age. And >> here's
the truth. You were afraid of getting docks. Europe. Okay. I
I would implore for you to just use your brain and think about
how positively I covered Destiny in the meantime and whether
that had any effect on on him trying to dox me or not. Um but
obviously, you know, you're typing the things you're typing.
I'm making an impossible request. It's fine. At some point, when
it becomes a pattern, you got to sit there and question like,
is he a victim? Did he get set up? Or is this are these types
of situations that he wants to be in? Is he turned on by the
idea that he could be talking to a kid? You have to question
that.
And this is one of those situations. Obviously, you can be lied
to about somebody's age and be a victim where it's like, well,
[__] I thought I went above and beyond to check that
she was above age or whatever, but you know, I got this. This
guy's trying to say that he was right about something. I see
he's got the Kelly Jean gene.
Admit that I was right. Admit that I was right. She lied. She
showed me fake ID. Whatever the case, right? There are situations
where you can be a victim, but this is not one of them in my
opinion. So, I mean, these DMs are brutal. Let's go back. You
know what, Cherry, you're right. Okay.
I don't know if this is working. It really offsets. Okay. If
you've got a monitor tan,
brown might not be your color. I'm I'm going to be real. All
right. It might not be her age. before I talked to her. >> When
navigating Kiwi Farms, the hacker himself would clarify in a
later post to Rose's knowledge Destiny did not know her real
age. And even if he did, he did not make it known to her. I don't
believe Destiny is a Now, apparently, there are DMs jokingly
asking for ID, commenting on how young she looks. >> If
I go to a club and I someone underage, it doesn't matter that
I ask for their age, if they turn out to be younger, you're still
going to get prosecuted the same way. It's like the onus is only
crime. use that as a defense only to a point, especially if there
are if there are other reasons to believe this person could be
underage as there is in this case. Um, or at least we're not
sure. >> No, I don't think we can confirm their identity.
So, versus boyfriend says she was 17 at the time, and I don't
know if she says she was 18 or 19 at the time of >> I get
what you're getting at. I need more before I'm comfortable. >> Now,
obviously, she's going to sit there and say that she's 18, right?
The boyfriend says she's 17. She's going to be she's going to
say she was 18 or 19. Why? Because she was selling nudes to people
on Twitter. So, she kind of has to say that. And that's another
thing, too, right? Destiny can't just be like, "Well, she told
me she was 18, dude. I mean, [__] What was I supposed
to do?" Yeah, she's selling nudes >> again. As we said
last night, she's selling nudes on a non-ageverified
platform,
right? There isn't age verification on the platform. Why is she
only selling nudes on non-ageverified platforms? That would be
She's 18. You found her with under the teen NSFW tag.
She's only selling these nudes on certain websites.
I feel like the I think the damning thing for me is Destiny's
lies about her using Tinder and Tinder was age verified and then
the other lie was that she had an Only Fans account. I believe
that's Destiny who propagated that first, right? That she had
an Only Fans account. Like those are indicative of his mindset
and how confident he was that she was above the age of consent
or sorry, well that is also true. Not just above the age of consent
but also an adult.
Why would he be Why would he be lying about her being on age
verified platforms if she was a child? Oh, she told you she was
18. The she has to
selling nudes. She's not going to tell you. She's not going to
be honest with you about her age.
You have to figure that out. >> Going that far. Wasn't
able to ever find me this message. So, I asked Destiny about
it. Did she ever engage with you or like show you like a site
where maybe it did check for age verification at any
>> No, yes. Yes. Yeah. like she was like an active user
of um I think Tinder to find hookups and [__] >> Listen
to how it how long it takes Destiny to come up with something.
Uh
um Oh. Oh, she used Tinder for hookups. We'll get into that.
>> Yes. Yes. Yeah. So, like she was like active user of
um I think Tinder to find and Tinder does um is 19 or older.
>> And Destiny sent messages he had with Rose and her talking
about using Tinder. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years, so
I don't know. Google says it verifies >> No, it doesn't.
Tinder didn't introduce age verification until last year. Well,
after all this stuff took place, >> this was something
we were actually pretty annoyed about Willie for that he didn't
bother to go look up like times here and he just propagated this
out like with a with no for no reason. Right. I think this was
a part of our criticism of Willy's second video at the time if
I'm not mistaken. We went and just looked. You just Google it
and it's like no Tinder did not have this process. Tinder might
ageverify now. Slime. It did not age verify back then. >> I
know Willie is compromised but I lose it if he finds a way to
defend this. >> Thank you for the $10. So, Tender said
Tender announces ID verification is expanding to users in the
US, UK, Brazil, and Mexico. Now, here's the thing, right? We
figured out
when uh let me see here. We figured out when this stuff happened.
So, in 2021, right? All Tender hat for verification. They had
photo verification to make sure that you're not a catch. You
got a blue
Augie bringing out the tables. Augie's building tables for his
stream. What? patch introduced in 2020. Users would submit selfies
to match profile photos and this confirms visual likeness, not
age or identity. ID ver >> Oh, it's just a chat GPT. Yeah,
it is just a chat GPT
was available voluntarily announced in August 2021. Users in
some regions could submit ID, but no separate batch existed.
It was only for internal verification. So, there was ID verification
that was optional, but it's not like you would know like if a
user you're interacting with ID verified themselves to be above
age. No badge of that existed until last year.
There was no combined badge. Uh legal age assurance was only
mandatory in Japan.
This is because of a Japanese law that was introduced in 2019.
So in Japan on Japanese tender,
they said that uh you had to show your your age uh to use the
app. You you had to prove your age or whatever, right? And you
proved this through some sort of like health insurance card or
medical insurance, something like that, right?
>> Pretty sure Tinder's verification now amounts to a uh
face age classification using AI. Maybe
she's telling me Quimman would be views on Tinder, too. AI will
always be fooled by Quimman's face. No badge tied to age. Now,
in 2024,
uh, separate photo verification badges exist, ID verification
badges exist, and if you have done both photo and ID verification,
you get blue check mark to show that you're like a legitimate
account, to show that you're not a catfish and that you're above
the age of consent.
And this was all introduced
last year. So when Willie says in this video like I don't know
I googled it. You know Tinder says if they verify it not true.
>> It depends on your location too. It's not even it's
not even required.
>> It's up to state law if state law wants to require it.
And we looked it up. We looked at the state that the girl is
from and that state does not require
>> Yeah. We looked at this at the time when Willy's video
came out. This is a criticism of Willy's video when it came out.
All right. No Afro Samurai. I'm not doing that. I'm not. No thank
you. Uh >> ID verification to use Tinder. So Destiny's
whole excuse here, Destiny's excuse of like, well, I know that
she used Tinder, so I just assumed that she was above the age
consent. That's about as like meaningful as if Destiny said like,
well, she plays Grand Theft Auto and Grand Theft Auto is rated
M for 17 and up, so I assumed that she was 18. That's like the
same level of argumentation, right? Cuz Tender doesn't require
that. So yeah, it's it's as if you said like, well, she plays
Mr. Rated video games. Yeah, anyone can do that. Anyone could
be on Tinder unless you live in a state that requires you by
law to prove that you're 18.
>> Okay, hold on. Let me get past this.
>> It doesn't send me. >> Oh, yes. Yes. >> That's
crazy. >> This is the lie right here. This is the >> Okay,
stop. This is crazy. >> Slime is Callum.
Is it actually?
>> And Tinder does um is 18 or older. >> And Destiny
sent messages he had yet with Rose and her talking about using
Tinder. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years, so I don't know.
Google says it verifies age. There needs to be more tangible
evidence right now. >> Dude, that's classic Willie research
right there. Okay. Absolutely classic Willie research. Listen,
Google said Tinder rage verifies, so I'm just going to put that
in my video. Amazing.
>> The worst case scenario is that she might have lied
to. And that's the end of the good news. >> No. No. Sorry.
But uh yeah, that segment right there, the way that ends off,
it's like uh that's not the only tangible evidence. I do agree
with Willie, especially at the time that he made it that there
needs to be more evidence before he can make the claim that he's
obviously, but worst case scenario is not just that she lied
about her age. It's that he was negligent in proving that she
was an adult. He even allegedly makes comments that he doesn't
know. It's not it's not like negligent even or it's like um
it's like willful negligence, right? It's like
it's like it's so negligent that you have to wonder if it's just
like they're just creating some plausible deniability. That's
it, right? It's just it's the exact same thing as the tenant
contracts for Tim Pool and Benny Johnson where they're like,
"Hey, uh could you show some evidence that this company like
exists or this guy's real?" And they're like, "Here's basically
nothing." And they're like, "Yeah, it's just, you know, $150,000
a month. Let give me the money. Give me the money. Give me the
money." It's not It's not even like reckless. It's that you have
a good idea that you are doing the bad thing, but you don't care
cuz you want the bad thing,
right? It's not just like reckless. It's not like, "Oh, the bad
thing might be true." It's like you kind of want the bad thing.
You kind of want you you're good with it, right? >> No.
Right. So, yeah. And the whole tender thing is just completely
incorrect there. I mean, it did not take that much long to figure
out that like yeah, tender does not have like a you don't need
to be a use tender. You can get on that app very easily if you're
a minor and only recently has begun to take sort of introduce
some sort of ID verification system even in place. >> So,
oh look, Alex Gekmo. Alex Gekko gets it. There he is. Alex Gekkmo,
stop saying negligent. It was willful ignorance. Yes. It's like
understanding that it's it's even likely that this person is
not above the age of 18, right? There's a very good chance that
this person is not above the age of 18, but you're like, "Well,
I got I've got the logs now that say you you told me you're 18."
Wow. >> Yeah.
All right. What else do we got here? So, this is Pixie coming
out. And so, she put out a very interesting statement. She says,
"Destiny knew. He knew the age. >> Destiny knew." >> And
so, Destiny had a very interesting response to this. I'm not
even sure why what he was smoking here. Again, Destiny's just
crazy. He's just fully >> This is the Russell search logs,
right? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Oh, no. He posted the
>> Desi says, "Remember, guys, unless." >> So, Pixie
says, "I'm not sure. I'm pretty boring. I feel like I told you
everything, but I'm not sure. I learned how to bartend Loki in
New York. Nothing fancy. Just a college bar and some simple drinks."
Desi says, "Ooh, even being underage, they let you." Pixie says,
"Yeah, they didn't care." Also, I'm pretty sure the owner of
the bar, it's totally evading taxes or misrepresenting his numbers
to IRS. Everything there is based on cash. Desi says, "Ah, yeah,
people do a ton of cash business, then yeah, usually." Pixie
says, "Also, I had a I had to fake an ID to get into most bars/
clubs in New York City. No one really cares where your ID is
from." So that's >> guys, isn't this really just an issue
about not validating IDs? Ultimately, isn't that what people
are mad at me for? Not like validating IDs, not doing, you know,
like ID. Isn't that what people are actually mad about? No, it's
you having interactions with a child. It's you trying to fly
a 17-year-old to Miami to you. That's what people are mad about.
Okay, that's what people are actually annoyed about. Just so
we're all clear. It's not about whether somebody had a fake ID.
It's not about anything like that. 's own on Pixie is that she
faked an ID to get into some bars and also to work at one. That's
that's the [__] I don't even understand. That's the
own. She faked an ID to get into a bar which is as bad as Destiny
sending and receiving CS Sam with a minor. This the same thing.
Remember, >> bro, hold on.
Just >> What What did What did Pixie tweet today? What
is this? What is this? >> Have we seen this?
>> Oh no.
Do you know what the double irony is here? Do you guys know the
DG drama about Leon the Professional that literally they they
got movies disabled in DGG chat? Okay,
because they were watching this movie and spamming the emote
whenever Natalie Portman was on screen. Okay,
when like 12-year-old Natalie Portman was on screen, they got
movies removed from that chat because they were all spamming
it. All right. I have never watched Leon the Professional. So
this line I did not know about this lie.
>> Want to see my license?
>> No,
you just look a little younger.
>> Wow. Uh, real life imitates fiction, doesn't it? That's
[__] up. Sorry. That's amazing.
>> Check out you guys. Unless Oh, you faked an ID. Got
him. It's like all this guy can do is deflect, but even here,
this is like the >> Oh, wait. Aie is showing the tweet
in two seconds. Oh, I didn't even know. >> I didn't even
know the tweet was in his >> And somehow DG will eat this
up. What the What is this? It's probably morally worse to serve
alcohol to 17-year-old than it is to receive nude pictures from
once. What? Hold on. Hold on. That's a red flag. That's a red
flag right there.
what? What? What? Dude,
what? That's why That's why every movie about being about like
graduating high school is high schoolers drinking at parties,
right? Sorry, not high school. It has high schoolers sending
nudes to adults, right? Oh, no. It's the high schoolers drinking
at parties. That's the one that's like totally accepted by all
of modern culture. Not this one. This is only in our house films.
Okay. I don't know what the >> What the We're not setting
their best. What? Yo, dude. I mean, this has just got to be like
reply bait. This has got to be like rage bait to make Destiny
look bad, right? I mean, what are we even doing here?
serving a drink with >> that's Auggie is Auggie is making
the mistake that I made for a long time. Okay, in that he thinks
there's a bar for this kind of behavior. There is no bar. Every
time you think there's a bar,
the bar goes lower every single time. >> 17-year-old
is worse than sending and receiving nude pictures from ones.
These people are just Wow. Okay,
so Pixie follows this up. She continues on her Twitter account.
He says, "Oh, the amount of things I wish I could tell everyone
right now, and boy, can I not wait. I have a feeling it's only
going to get worse and worse and worse from here. I feel like
Destiny is just so Oh, she posted something else."
>> How old are you?
>> Want to see my license? >> No, I just look a little
younger.
>> 17. What's the big deal? >> Augie's not a knower.
>> Unlucky. Augie's not a knower, guys.
Okay, this is the cherry tweet points. Apparently, he's a conservative,
but he's like a big fan of Destiny. I'm not really I don't know
too much about this guy, but apparently he went live last >> Dude,
I just got to watch I didn't get a chance to see these Augie
reactions. I'll be honest. I was driving around a lot today.
Okay. And I was listening to some of Augie's stream while I was
um while I was driving around. So, I didn't get to this part,
though. So, I'm I'm excited now.
>> I haven't watched this clip yet. Let's just see it.
>> I'm not going to lie. I've been trying to cover other
things besides Destiny. uh just to mix it up and make sure that
we don't become a Destiny Rewatch channel. Uh however, truth
be told, there's a reason why he's the most popular streamer
in liberal.
>> I don't want to become a Destiny Rewatch channel. Proceeds
to react to the Nathan Benell versus Drew Pavlau debate. I don't
want to be Guys, guys, guys. I don't want to be a Destiny Rewatch
channel or anything. Proceeds to immediately react to the the
Drew Pavloo
Nathan Banell debate.
Okay, listen. You're a loser. you're a loser. If you even react
to that debate, to be honest, you can mock it, you can laugh
at it, but like if you're going to go watch that whole debate
and pretend that there's anything to entertain there,
it's weird. It's weird. Okay, >> I don't care if you got
permission from Destiny. Obviously, that guy doesn't act with
his child's best interest at heart. Okay, you are more responsible.
Okay, Connor, you you care way more about that kid than than
he does, okay, than Destiny does. So, please, next time, do the
right thing. Give it a skip. Okay,
pull your smug bug card. Skip. Next. Skip. No, don't need this
one. Don't need this one. >> He's constantly the center
of attention and drama. >> Dude, does everyone just have
to suck this guy off every time they talk about him? Listen,
I know things are going bad with Destiny right now. He's the
best we've got. He's so good at just getting
Is he even really good at that anymore? >> Play the Connor
clip. Dude, the Connor clip's rough. Okay, Connor clip is rough.
Uh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me pull this from chat real
quick. I'm going to get more caffeine. I'll be honest, I had
a lot of caffeine. I'm going to go get more caffeine. >> Her
nudes on the internet. You could probably presume that she's
engaging as >> Oh, yes, Riyle. Just so you know, Ry, you
always time stamp stuff like 5 to 10 seconds. Too late. Even
know that that's a lie.
bro. How how girl who is selling her nudes on the internet? You
could probably presume that she's engaging as an adult. And if
she looks >> Connor just justified all child purchases
on the internet. Like literally, if that was the logic you could
go with, that is not a minor. Okay, here's the thing. I think
that if you see a girl Okay, hold on. Connor literally just justified
the Leon the professional seed, right? He just justified buying
nudes from Natalie Portman. That's what Connor just did. >> How
old are you?
>> Want to see my license? >> He just he just justified
it. Okay. Hey, if she's selling news, that means that uh she's,
you know, you can assume she's an adult on her one day old Twitter
account. Her I believe the Twitter account was made what, like,
was it April 1st? I believe it was made in April. It was made
like April 1st or something was the date the Twitter account
was created if I'm not mistaken. So, it could have been what,
like four or five days old.
>> Who is >> Yeah, I'm pretty sure that account's
definitely an 18-year-old guy >> selling her nudes on the
internet, you could probably presume that she's engaging as an
adult. And if she dude, dude,
putting the CPA counter points like I assume that this is too
humiliating to continue. I assume that this is just way too humiliating
for these people to continue with. Wrong.
>> every time you make that assumption, you are wrong.
Every time you make that assumption, you are wrong. Dude, I feel
like I feel like I've gotten to the point where I think Connor
is like trying not to really give his own responses or answers.
Connor's like reading from a script. He might actually be doing
some kind of like chat GPT scripting of his stream because I
think he knows if he takes any moral position at all. Destiny
will immediately violate that. If Connor was like, "Yeah, uh,
listen, where's the line for me?" Probably Destiny a dog or something.
Destiny will post a video of himself a dog the next day instantly.
That dog will be getting railed on stream and he will laugh about
it and everybody will go, "It's just like dog." And they'll all
laugh and clap for him. Oh, it's just like dog words.
And Conor will sit there and go like, "Well, you know what, guys?
I realize I just said that was my position that if he dog him
out, but actually, you know, is it really that bad? Is it really
that bad, guys? Come on. Come on, dude. This is this is unironically.
This is how I feel like Counterpoints has stopped giving his
own positions now cuz he knows that if he states anything, it
will immediately be violated." Okay. >> Uh, truth be told,
there's a reason why he's the most popular streamer in liberal
news media. There's a reason why >> is he even the most
popular streamer? I feel Dean Withers is more popular than this
guy. Is he really the most popular streamer in liberal news media?
>> Why he's constantly the center of attention and drama?
It's because he get >> I mean other people stream in that
in that space, right? See the is he Yeah. Is he the most prominent
liberal streamer primarily? Maybe
other streamers are big have bigger platforms. Other people who
do stream have bigger platforms, right? Majority report is 2x
him now. I see. Even in terms of live viewers as well, maybe.
I'm trying to think. I I don't know what the majority reports
live viewership is >> He gets into fights with other people
all the time. Uh which is what we'll be talking about today.
Grill Shalah. Indeed. Indeed. Um how old was Rose? No idea. 1718.
Now I >> 17 what? >> Care. Uh let let me tell you
why I don't care. Uh we already knew that. We've known that for
a year. >> We've known that for a year. Is Destiny cool
with this guy saying this, by the way? Because that's not what
Destiny's saying. Destiny's not coming out saying
>> if only Auggie knew that. That's literally not what
Counterpoints was saying like 3 months ago. 3 months ago for
Counterpoints, he was saying this girl is 1819. 6 months ago
for Counterpoints, he's saying this girl's 1819. It's not just
that Destiny wasn't saying that. It's that Connor wasn't even
saying that. >> Guys, we've known for a year. Who Who cares?
This guy's saying that. Is Destiny cool with this as a defense?
We all knew. Who's we, by the way? We Who's we? Ariodite.
>> Okay, I hate to I hate to take this like 60sec Auggie
segment. I know Auggie's in chat. is probably, you know, lapping
this up. He loves watching himself on stream, I'm sure. But now
I literally have to go and and show the tweets cuz like I don't
know. I don't know what the this guy was on today. This Destiny
guy, this Destiny guy was losing it. I'm going to go cover this
LE thread real quick. Okay, cuz he basically admits in this thread
that like yes, she is 17. Yes, she was found successfully. Yes,
I did. Like he admits so many [__] things in this
in this chain just to maintain like but I didn't think she was
18 or 17. I didn't think she was underage. Like he's losing it.
He's giving up every plausible deniability defense he has. Right.
Other than I just didn't think she was 18. I don't know. I don't
know man. Where is at Nestie tonight? I haven't seen him in here
in the past couple days. I don't know man. He's not banned. I
don't think. Okay.
So, he's complaining about Hassan. Hassan is bad, guys. What
about Hassan? I don't even know what the Hassan clip is. Ellie
asked him, "I'm so curious. Do you still think you can't sweep
and meme your way through this like you did with the non-consensual?
Or if not, what changed your mind?" If she was a legit minor,
can you tell me why no one seems to care that Solo was legitimately
trafficking her and using her to honeypot people? Those are federal
felonies, by the way. Uh, we could also be concerned about that.
We can actually be concerned about both at the same time. I don't
know if D I don't know if Destiny understands this, but regardless
of how bad Solo's actions are, he is still just as culpable for
his own actions.
Solo Solo could be doing any crazy, okay? Destiny is still culpable
for his own actions. He's still culpable for his own complete
disregard for whether or not this person was 18. He's still culpable.
Doesn't matter, man.
Actually, I've been thinking this is this is o I've been thinking
this over. Oh god, I just clicked through. Actually, I've been
thinking this over. I would like to see the police look into
this if for no reason other than the girl or that he could be
exploiting other girls. Only one of us can make that happen.
Want redemption statement? Go to the police tomorrow and give
them everything you have. This is the This is the juicy one.
Okay,
I have nothing to give them. Remember, the only reason they even
found Rose, he's talking about Kiwi Farms, was because I posted
the pics in chat to bait them into looking.
Can you imagine posting this to say the only reason they found
out this they found this girl who's a minor when I was sex with
her was because I tried to bait them into looking for her. What?
So hold on. Wait, what? What is it you accused uh me of? Playing
footsies with Kiwi Farms. You accused me of playing footsies
with Kiwi Farms. And he's like, I actually was reading Kiwi Farms
directly responding to their bait. And I posted pictures of this
minor when she was a minor only wearing a t-shirt to try to get
her doxed. Yeah. Yeah. Uh why are you saying this? Why are you
saying this? Why? Dude, seems pretty stupid to do to do that
if I thought she was 17. Huh? Hold on. So this I think the important
thing another important thing to highlight here, okay, is it's
like wait, can you post the evidence that you had that she was
18? Right. So, you you tried to get her found. You post like
why you thought she was 18? And please don't say that it was
just that she told you she was 18. Please don't say that it was
just her words in a Twitter DM saying or in a Discord DM saying
I'm 18 or I'm 19. Please tell me you have any other element,
any other fact to go on.
Please, please,
cuz right all all that matters here now is he says, "Well, this
is pretty stupid to do if I thought she was 17." Right? Not necessarily.
Not necessarily, man. It's pretty stupid to do if you just didn't
have concrete proof she was 18 for you.
It's so stupid, in fact, that our relevant couldn't believe that
you did it. Literally could not believe it. He was like, "No,
that would be so if you didn't have like bulletproof evidence
she was 18. Wonder if any of them will spend half the effort
looking for the child trafficker." H. And uh Ellie B responds,
"You have plenty of evidence." that is all your chat logs, every
other correspondence you've had on the subject. Tell them you're
worried that this guy is exploiting kids and spreading revenge
for Why not? You've made a huge mess of everything in your life.
You can still try to do good. Uh, also, wouldn't you have like
a bunch of this guy, the Cam you've obtained from from Rose?
Wouldn't you be able to go to the police with that and say, "Yeah,
this was sent to me. I didn't know. And I'm at your mercy, but
can you find the guy who's trafficking this poor girl?" I have
to be sympathetic to Destiny. I don't always ask for ID when
I look for 18-year-old. Barely legal. Thank you for the post
dickers. Jesus Christ, dude. Or Dingolingus. That's not Dickers.
I thought that was Dickers. I miss Red. I miss Red.
Jesus. Tell them you're worried that this guy is exploiting kids
and spreading revenge pool. Why not? You've made a huge mess
of everything in your life. You can still try to do good.
That's responds in the process of doing that with my law firm
in NYC, but the random extortion lawsuit that Pixie decided to
drop on me, plus everyone else trying to push their own agenda
on this has exhausted my ability to do so. Oh well, at least
it's getting some attention on Discord for people. Don't forget
to take your anti-anxiety and antiscychotics before you sleep.
Ellie, it's shocking to me that Destiny will shame people for
getting their their anything that's wrong with them looked into
when this guy clearly needs like years of therapy right now.
Okay, this guy's like out here making fun of other people for
trying to take care of themselves and he needs like Dude, realistically
Ellie, I think you should be charitable here and share whatever
that is. Okay, if that's real. I don't know if it's real, but
if it's real, could you do the kind thing and at least share
half of that with Destiny cuz he needs something. Okay, he is
crashing the out. It's dude. Okay, this tweet there's there's
like a mountain with this tweet. Okay. Um, he was in the process
of finding Solo, but the random extortion lawsuit that Pixie
decided to drop on me, plus everyone else trying to push their
own agenda. What does this mean? Why did Why would this affect
your ability to go try to find Solo? Why would this affect your
ability to hire like a private investigator to go find
That's nothing compared to Andy Bee's bills, right? You'd easily
go find this solo guy. Uh, I don't I don't even know what his
possible rationale is here. And this is another thing to me.
So we combined the lies about the age verific verified platforms,
right? When did Destiny unblock you on Twitter? I noticed you
quote tweeted him tonight a couple weeks or a couple days ago.
So the constant lies about the age verified platforms, right?
And him leaking these things. Like I think, sorry, the constant
lies about the age verified platforms and his dropping of this
NYC thing, dropping trying to find Solo that makes me think he
was nowhere near as certain that she was 18 as he pretends to
be. Right. What he dropped that he has a totally thin like thin
flimsy wafer thin justification for it. Right. It means
And
he's he's made little consistent lies along the way that try
to imply she's 18 without those having any factual basis to them.
Like is there not is he not been dropping breadcrumbs that he
probably suspected she was actually a minor? I feel like he is.
I feel like it's clear. And then everyone else, apparently me
or Queman or Chud or whoever covering this is uh impeding his
ability to seek legal relief. I don't understand how, but apparently
it is. He couldn't possibly go find Solo. And now, despite the
fact that he dropped Solo because people were making fun of him
on the internet that he dropped trying to find the guy, he is
going to virtue signal about finding the guy. Well, why aren't
these people trying to find him?
Why aren't you trying to find him? Oh, interesting point, Jacob,
that you raised. So, also, can you post your like legal fees
with the NYC law firm? Can we get some some receipts of that?
Cuz he said he got his NYC law firm to look into getting his
removed from Kiwi Farms. And then we found out that it was just
Nu sending an email with his name on it that said, "Hey, could
you please remove my from your site?" Right.
So, that wasn't his law firm looking into it. Has that law firm
really done anything? I said, "Nu." I said, "I think it's an
assistant." I have no idea if it's Nu. I didn't mean to introduce
Nino's name. I have no idea. I have no idea if Nenu is actually
working for him still. And if she is, it's a job. It's a job.
It's not a big deal. Okay. Wait, is Darius stare on 7TV? What
the heck? What the heck? Oh, it is cool. Yeah, exactly. Minecraft
Beamer.
>> Exactly. Seemed like his logs were >> placating
Pixie not really trying to help in any way.
Seems pretty clear. Hold on. Break. Possibly breaking news. Possibly
breaking news.
Woo! Woo! Putting AE on indefinite
Woo! Woo! Woo! Apparently, apparently. Apparently. Okay, now
I I don't know if this is real. I don't know if this is just
a joke. Maybe it's just a joke. Okay, maybe it's just a joke.
Is it just a joke, guys? Is it just a Is it just a joke? Moot's
on vacation for 3 weeks. I'll see where everything is at then.
Could just be a joke. Could just be a joke. Could just be Could
be just bait. Okay, it could just be bait.
I don't know, man. I don't know. I'm sorry, but like, yeah, I
have a hard time believing he's quitting AE. Okay, it's a lot
of money. We'll see. We'll see in the end what happens with that.
Okay, we're still on this. We're still on this thread, guys.
So, we're checking this out because of the counterpoint stuff
where what was counterpoint.
>> Who we
This guy's saying that is cool with this as a defense. We all
>> counter scope to remember. >> Who's we? Ariodite
Dan Food Shops who's apparently like one of the new people in
Destiny's orbit now. Food shops the uh you know I don't even
Who is we?
>> Uh we already knew that. We've known that for a year.
Uh >> did Destiny know that for a year? >> I can't
remember what got me to pull up the le thing. I think it was
just me showing that he that Desi like actually he basically
says and like I dude I don't want to I don't want to overstate
it but just going back to this one that I quote tweeted. It seems
like he's actually saying the only reason they found that Rose
person was because I posted the pics in chat to bait them into
looking. Is he not saying that he's like intentionally trying
to get her doxed? Is that not I feel like that's what it's saying,
but I don't know. I don't want to overread it. Okay, that seems
to be what it's saying to me. That seems Dude, he is like saying
he did this intentionally. What? Why? I'm really again. Okay,
I'm re again, bro. This guy is getting more insane. He's getting
more unhinged. She's getting less rational and I don't understand
what's going on. Like at this point if you act like a to this
extent there's no even let's say no no hold on let's say he like
somehow pulls something and goes like oh look I fooled you guys
into covering some it's like okay you fooled me by being a like
by being a literal admitting to things that you apparently are
now saying are like even if something came out later right I
don't like there's no way that he could somehow turn this I'm
just I'm so lost on like how any DJ could be coping at this point.
Destiny ever admitted that he wasn't completely in control for
one second. His view of himself would completely collapse.
A man. Okay. After the the meds comment, we continue.
Ellie responds, "You understand that your deflection isn't working,
right?" Pixie isn't preventing you from going to the authorities
and reporting a case of child exploitation that you have evidence
for. Aren't you tired of this man? She's kind of just like totally
destroying him. It's [__] hilarious. She's just totally
owning him right now,
right? He is totally owned. He is owned in every possible way.
Oh Jesus. Let me know when you guys go after Solo. I'll be waiting
to help.
What? Why? Hold on. I thought you were just moralizing about
Solo. Wasn't you just saying that this is horrible? They don't
even care about Solo. Don't Do you care about Solo? Bro, I'm
about Solo just cuz apparently there could be child exploitation
going on there. Shouldn't you be like double P at Solo? Didn't
that guy leak all your revenge and [__] up your life?
Shouldn't you be even more upset at Solo than anybody else?
Aren't you the biggest victim here by your own words? Don't you
say you're the biggest victim and you don't want to go after
Solo because people are going after you? What kind of tripling
down on victimization garbage is that? Well, this guy ruined
my life. He spread my revenge, made everybody aware of all the
[__] I was doing. But I don't want to go after him
cuz Pixie's mean to me. Jay Dog's mean to me. Queen is mean to
me.
Really, bro? Are you that much of a to either revenge against
Rose for giving her account details to Solo or trying to dox
her so it helps Destiny get closer to Solo's identity. But I
don't even believe he wants Solo's identity.
Honestly, at this point, I believe he's so spiteful to everybody
that I I don't know, man. Like I it seems like he's not even
saying that he wants to go after Solo. I like I again there's
no rational there's no threat of rationality that I can like
weave through this and have it stay connected. There's like so
many so many places where the the the thread is severed, right?
There's no thread I can weave through all of these actions to
make it make sense. Okay, let me know when you guys go after
Solo. I'll be waiting to help. Nope. That this one's all you,
Steven. This battle is one you're going to have to fight with
yourself. Keep doing what you're doing or grow up. Nobody left
for you to point the finger at. You know I'm right. I get to
walk away from this. You have to live with this with yourself
forever. And Desi responds with a picture of Shaylen.
And Ellie responds, I don't know this reference picture of Shaylen.
Thanks. That helps. So, are you going to the police?
Picture of Shaylen. Okay. Why are you trying so hard to draw
clicks to a conversation in which you concede that she was a
minor? There's no way you think the best defense you have right
now is I didn't know or I wouldn't have posted that picture.
That is what he thinks his best defense is. Which makes you understand.
It just helps you understand. Okay. It helps you understand how
he is in his own head, right?
That this is what he's going with.
Guys, I tried to dox that minor because uh because I didn't think
she was a minor. That's why I tried to dox that person that people
told me was a minor. Um, yeah. Also, people who play footsies
with kiwi farms are like the worst people and they deserve to
get doxed. Actually, picture of Shayen. It is, isn't it? That's
rough, dude.
She post the logs again. Uh, picture of
Does she still post after? No. Oh, he's here. Augie, are you
still here? He's back. He's back. He's back. Augie, he's back
to watch. He's here. Is Augie still
Dude, no way. That's crazy.
That's crazy. Oh my god. Oh boy. I don't know, man.
This guy shows up. Say the line, Destiny. I really don't like
Cherry. That's all he comes in this chat to say. This is very
embarrassing. Destiny, will you, now that you're here and watching,
will you go to the police with all of the info you have on Solo?
Apparently, you were sent videos of solo bros, which we now know
is C Sam. Are you going to go to the police with that evidence?
You going to do the right thing? This is actually funny because
there's a chance that if you went with all of that evidence,
you might get some kind of deal, right? You might get like some
kind of they might they might even say, "Oh, well, you didn't
know. Yeah, come in here and you give us evidence of this. We'll
catch this guy." But it would be a risk be a risk to you. I think
personally I think you'll just stay home. All right. Are we back
to the Are we back to the Auggie clip? Oh, yes. We're back to
the Augie clip with him reacting to counter points. Let's check
it out. >> That like
>> Thank you for the $5. >> Rose was like living
with her parents and all that kind of [__] So, well,
maybe not a year. Maybe >> self-described. You can just
say I mean I don't even know enough about food shops. I think
I watched like a crazy chologic panel with them like two years
ago. But apparently that is something that I've only heard the
worse. I've heard crazy allegations. I just don't want to repeat
stuff that I don't know. But yeah, apparently this is Destiny.
>> Oh, I don't know if Destiny is still here. I'm being
informed, okay, by
by people who wish to remain anonymous. That the Dan clip is
not the Dan logs are not bait. Okay, Dan can no longer afford
to be associated
with somebody who solicits minors for and trafficking. Okay,
somebody tries to traffic minors, Dan cannot be associated with
that. Okay, he barely dodged the Diddy Bullet. He cannot be associated
with people like that. All right.
He can't do it. Bro keeps admitting to being given content. What?
No way. Hold on. What is this? What is this? What is this? Wait,
why can't I see? Oh, Jesus. Wait, I have never paid anyone for
anything. And that was media they claimed to have made with their
partner. Okay. Like, yeah, he did. Yeah, he didn't pay, but he
he did solicit nudes. Absolutely. He absolutely solicited nudes.
Dude, this is uh
remember when this PDF said he was going to have more viewers
than Hassan by the end of the year? I do remember that. In fact,
I do remember it. I do remember that happening. Hold on. Hold
on. I might I might even have a little picture of that or something
here somewhere.
Where would it be? Where would it be? Where would it be? >> I
have no idea actually. Udachi, thank for the five gifted. Let's
go.
Play the clip. That's your man's.
>> You know they got your man. They got your mans on charges.
>> Yeah, then you be hanging with, >> bro. Why would
you link me this and not the uh not the one from my timeline?
God. Okay, I'll be real. I don't know where I saved the Where
is this?
I used to have this on my waiting screen. I lost it. Okay, imagine
I posted this Destiny right now. Okay, Destiny being like, I'll
have more viewers than Hassan. I'll have more concurrent viewers
than Hassan by the end of 2025. Where's the prediction? Where's
it at? >> Destiny's raiding into this food shops person
every night and they're just running non-stop Destiny defense
streams and stuff like that. It's crazy. >> November. November.
So, we've known that she was living with her parents and was
stupid and all that [__] Uh, >> okay. Let me
hear more of this guy. >> Year. Maybe November. November.
So, we we've known that she was living with her parents and was
stupid and all that. Um, so I don't know. 17 years old, 364 days
and and 11. >> Oh my god, bro. Really? We're doing the
stupid [__] meme. She was 17 and 364. Actually, when
they started uh talking, she was uh 17 and a half. It's not like
she was like a day from turning 18. What the [__]
is this defense, right? >> This one.
That's the log. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Oh god,
you just love to see it. Couldn't have happened to a nicer guy,
dude. There's no way. Hold on. Hello, old friend. Oh boy. Oh
boy. Five more LSF threads about Hassan will do it. 14k hours
is crazy. Hold on. Don't I have that beaten? Can I just open
my Steam right now and beat that easily? I have to have more
than 14,000 hours in Dota, right? Don't I have like 20,000 hours
in Dota? I posted it before. I feel like I'm I can mock this
with a game I haven't played in like six years.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Give me a second. Give me
a second. I think I I think I mo this pretty easily. Give me
a second.
Where's Dota? Where's Dota at? Dota 2. Dota 2. Dota 2. Dota 2.
Dota 2. Oh, I lied. He's got me. He's got me beat, guys. He's
got me beat. I've not played this game in almost four years,
though. I will say that. Okay. He's got me beat, but I've not
played it in almost four years.
8,900 hours. Unlucky.
Unlucky. Unlucky. Oh, please explain the joke. Yeah. So, Rust
is what Dan plays a lot of when uh when he wasn't streaming.
When he took a break from streaming before, when he took a break
from coming on Destiny's stream before, he played uh Rust. He
played Rust the whole time. Are you off by like 11K? Wait, not
11K. Like 3K. No, sorry. Sorry. Like 7K. N 6K. All right. Okay.
We need to Oh, we finished the thread. Wait, is there another
thing? Oh, I was just going to cover my
Yeah. Where's my tweet at? Yeah, this one. No, not this one.
This one. This one was funny. This is a good one. Okay,
dude. He You know that he doesn't have the A team anymore, right?
There's no way he still got an A team. you know, this B team
totally failed to to dox Rose. And so he's like explicitly just
like, "Well, I I challenged the I challenged KF to find her.
Okay, I I did
Dude, I'm I'm getting like interesting stuff. Okay, what is this?
Why did Reuben Rubin send me this? I've done it. I've weaponized
incompetence. Maha,
why did you Why am I getting pinged with the most ridiculous
that doesn't relate to the stream? I understand I'm like schizophrenic
and all over the place, but come on.
Why am I Why am I getting pinged with like the weirdest most
random [__]
What is happening? Okay. Okay. We're uh Oh, Ethan Ralph posting
memes from this >> First one to tip five. >> No way.
>> We'll repost this. We'll repost this. >> Funny.
Ethan Ralph reposting memes from the stream. Let's go. Lucas
J synth head getting the shout out.
Let's go.
Let's go. Turns out even Lucas had no idea how correct he was.
All right. None of us really really had any idea.
You know what, Destiny? I know exactly what you need to do. Destiny,
you can do it right now. Okay, Destiny, if you're still here
and you're still listening, I need you to go hop on food shop
stream. Okay, that's the only way to fix your optics. Okay, go
hop on. Put yourself back to a far put yourself beside a far
bigger. Go hang out with your best buddy. All right, that's the
only thing that can save you now. Okay, that's all. That's it.
If you guys don't know, this is what Destiny did during the Red
Pill arc. Okay, if he hangs out next to John Zurka, he looks
like he loves women. He looks like he's not a massive misogynist.
Okay,
he needs to go now. It's the only thing that can prevent him.
It's the only thing that can save him from the optics. Okay,
it's the only thing he has to go sit next to a far bigger.
Destiny, you know I'm right. You know I'm right. Get on the food
shop stream now. Do it now. For the love of God, please fix your
mic. You're blowing out our eardrums. No, you're the only person
who has a problem, Lisa. You're the only one. Everyone else is
fine. Oh, right. Didn't Destiny quote tweet Max as well? Am I
crazy? Wasn't there a Max quote tweet? We had what? We had uh
Mr. Girl come out today? He posted
Destiny isn't a boo. But I'll listen. Destiny isn't a He just
doesn't have morals. When rich men do whatever they want, this
is what they
This is the uh this is the Epstein theory, okay? That like once
you're rich enough, you just uh you kind of become a naturally,
okay? you have no morals and you're super rich, you just naturally
become People tell you you can't do it. People tell you you can't.
And then I think I think Desi just quote tweeted him and played
the uh >> cave looking for diamonds. That's funny. >> It's
not really a good meme even. >> I'm in the same looking
for minors cuz my attraction to minors is major. Can't even play
hopscotch without popping a rager. Always been a pervert. So
I accept the insults when I was a kid. I
>> Wait, what is this? I've never seen it before. Uh, that's
not true. Augie, why are you lying right now? Why are you lying?
Saying you never seen this. There's no way you haven't seen this
before. Get the [__] out of here. Okay. No, there's
no chance of this, Queenman. Because if this happened, then he
is 100. Then he did know. This is probably what Pixie was aware
of. Okay. That Rose asked Destiny to play Minecraft. This is
why she's like, "He knew. He knew. He knew." Dude. Oh
god. you, by the way. Oh, I have to say it. I I have to say it.
You know, he wouldn't skip that Minecraft playd date. Okay. If
he had Minecraft playd dates with other people that he had far
more responsibility for he skip next. No, thank you. But the
Rose Minecraft date, he would not skip that one. Okay. He'd be
there. He'd be there early. She did check the first Hold on.
Let me investigate. Let me investigate. What's the first here?
Sunset first.
Oh, also why didn't you invite me to your Minecraft server? Ooh,
been using one. I've been
Minecraft. Buttplug.
Butt plug. Butt plug. Minecraft. Butt plug. By the way, just
a fun fact. All DMs with him of like are like this. I get sent
like a lot of different people's DMs. They're all like this where
they like try to talk about normal human things and he immediately
redirects back to like every single time.
It's like this guy is a dude.
Jesus Christ. Okay. Are we God? We won. We won, guys. We got
the R. We got a Ralph retweet on a Jtock stream meme. >> Awesome
stuff. All right. Going to work back off of this Augie stream.
We're going to go back to his counter points. >> Just tip
$3. Okay. Okay. You got me. I
>> Thank you for the three Destiny minor craft. I mean,
just come out and say it, right? Just say that 17-year-olds.
>> Remember when he clowned on Arcadum for the same thing,
always making DM? I don't. But I listen, you're going to tell
me Destiny's projecting his weirdness on other people, I'm just
going to believe you basically every single time. >> Based
at that point, if you're going to do like the whole like, oh,
she was 17, 364, just say the 17-year-old is based at that point.
If you're going to go that far, I mean, it >> um so I don't
know. 17 years old, 364 days in and 11 hours. No idea. No idea.
And you know what? I hope that the entire drama of >> DG
or best marching orders. >> You know what my favorite thing
about DG orbiters is? So, it usually takes Destiny like a few
days at least to come up with like the propaganda talking points
to sort of like minimize what's going on. >> Error 4s one,
you cannot donate um Twitter links with numbers in them. They
break. So that Twitter link you gave me doesn't work >> on
to give a defense that doesn't sound too bad that like the average
can pick up and just spread without thinking right the days before
that propaganda is created. You have guys like counterpoints
just going live. They have to defend Destiny but they're not
given any lines. They don't know what to say. So they just end
up saying the stupidest imaginable. They haven't been >> This
is just such a great point, right? This is such a great point.
Augi made this point yesterday in chat like watching these people
watching the bots like not get their programming update and go
live and like talk about stuff. It's so funny >> poached
yet. They haven't been like brought into the private calls and
given to say given like the argumentation given the propaganda
to repeat and spread. They're just left to their own you know
whims and they just have to come up with something and they're
always so acid it. It's crazy. So you have this [__]
going live and just being like uh um we knew for years guys thinking
that that's going to be something that goes over well. >> Yeah.
And you know what? I hope that the entire drama of random people
on the internet, of sending homemade to various people, of having
it leaked, of getting sued over it, um I hope that has been and
will continue to remain a wakeup call for Steven to not be so
hedonistic and nihilistic.
>> Wait, who are these people referring to? Hold on, Neosc.
This isn't referring to Dan. You I think you've misunderstood
these logs. Let's take a look here. Uh Gobain Dan is mad tiny
doesn't give a [__] Dan is mad about something. Tiny
doesn't give a again. Radiant again. I wouldn't jump to conclusions.
Calling Destiny a sped and Dan a white blood cell is weird. This
is like about Pisco. Yeah, this is about Pisco.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Got it. Oh, Food Chops is a logging Pisco right
now.
You'll be fully down that road within 6 months, unfortunately.
Oh, Destiny came in to say Pisco is like that. Destiny, rip,
hang out with Aaron. Plus, becoming ingratiated with that community
means it's inevitable, but such is life. It turns out that
somehow we just people outside of Destiny, they somehow everybody
are thinking Destiny's like a bad person when really he's just
like the kindest person, right? He's like actually the best.
He's just a really good person. He's like a really really good
person, right? And somehow
me Quebin I don't even know who the other people would be. Britney
Simon, Lauren de Lagona, we all just like we all just these people.
Oh, straight raid. We all just these people into thinking that
Destiny's bad. It's not that, you know, his actions are just
that of like a total sociopath with no concern for other human
beings, right? That can't possibly be it. That can't possibly
be the answer. That he is literally not human. That can't possibly
be it. Okay,
that can't possibly be it. The [__] is this? Hold
on. This tweet perfectly encapsulates why Destiny's audience
have failed to damage Hassan in any meaningful way for the last
half decade. It literally justifies their earned reputation.
Here's the link to the clip Destiny posted in chat. It's not
hard to just click on it and watch it yourself. I honestly think
you could just you justify attacking this on IRL for statements
like this. Bro needs to bring out not so erodite so she can give
some of the good some of those empty good PR platitudes with
anime moing in the background. What is this? >> I just
I just think he's a like deeply good person even though he's
a very flawed person as well and he's a much better person than
he gives himself credit for. And it makes me sad, but since I've
been in directing, I see like this intentionality to try to take
responsibility and like to try to
>> And like, god damn, there's not a lot of people that
are trying. >> You guys, you guys know, you guys know what
the audio is from, right? You guys know what the audio is from,
dude. Cherry Cherry cooked so hard with that clip. It like actually
is so good. Oh, that's from the Cherry video. Okay, that audio
it is. Destiny is like his human
like I don't know
what's the monster. You guys know what the monster is, right?
That doesn't look human. It's basically like a angler fish, but
for humans. There's like a There's like an old lore like a crypted
that's like this, right? Destiny is like that, but Aerodite is
like the lure. The h the human lure. Okay, hold on.
Uh human angler fish lure. What is this? It's not It's not an
actual angler fish. Okay. But it's like a crypted that uses like
a an imp pale man. It's like it's not a human at all. No, it's
not pale man. It's not a human at all. No, you guys aren't going
to get it. I know what I'm talking about. You guys aren't going
to get it. I'm not giving you a good I'm not giving you a good
understanding of what it is. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind.
It's not Slender Man. It's a thing that uses like a human. Wait,
hold >> I will pay. >> But they're based on the same
thing. Zed
donated $5.
Genuine question. Why aren't there public calls to report this
to a child abuse hotline/ the FBI? These are serious crimes and
the docks of Rose can seriously hurt her if law enforcement doesn't
secure situ. >> Um I think basically anybody could report
this. If you if you feel like you need to report it, report it.
Um
I mean I would say it seems like something that should be reported.
It seems like it. Okay.
Um it should be. Yeah. No, it should be. Please play this. What
is
I have a hard time like arguing for a group action a lot of the
time. I think people should do what they're going to do, but
realistically in this case,
Okay, that's a crazy switch up right there. That's wild. The
hell? What the hell?
Okay, why why are you just linking me a Fentes clip? Okay, you
can't just give me five bucks and tell me I have to play a Fentes
clip. That's not how this works, Air Force One. All right, it's
going to cost you at least 10 bucks. At least 10. You got to
spot me a tener. I did want to laugh and just say that this is
uh this is absolutely happening now. This is absolutely happening.
I didn't think I'll be honest with you. I didn't think I didn't
think Rose being 17 was going to be Dan's breaking point. I didn't
see I thought Dan was in way deeper than that. Okay. I thought
he was in way deeper. I thought he would stay for sure over this
one. How much money are they making again? A decent amount. What
if Destiny promised she was 19 the whole time? I don't know.
Did he not draw a line anywhere? I don't know if he did. You
fool. You really think he's stepping away? I don't know, man.
I don't know.
Here. Keep watching this. I'm using the bathroom real quick and
then uh we're going to do this. We'll finish a little bit more
of the Auggie React and then I'm going to go to those new Pixie
Docs. We'll look at how he's getting in trouble for his whole
thing with um
getting in trouble for his whole thing, okay? With with leaking
that transcript, part of that transcript to food shops.
Oh, hold on.
I'm an empath. I know what's going on in people's minds. I'm
I've done two years of psychology. I can mind brain people. I
know what's going on. I bet you everyone has autism because I'm
going to diagnose everyone because I took one abnormal site class.
I'm the king of
>> Okay. I can't be the only one
who can't stop seeing the similarities between Aerodite and Food
Chops, right? >> Yeah, I'm
>> right. Like they're like the same person. Someone link
me that food chops clip from yesterday. >> I know what's
going on in people's minds. I'm I've done two years of psychology.
I can mind brain people. I know what's going on. I bet you everyone
has autism because I'm going to diagnose everyone because I took
one abnormal site class. I'm the king of psychology.
I'm an empath. I know what's going >> like they're the
they're like the exact same. It's crazy. But I need I need this
one. This is Knox Fox sent me this one.
Hold on. Hold on. Kids
out people's minds. I'm I've done two years of psychology. I
can mind read people. I know what's going on. I bet you everyone
has autism because I'm going to diagnose everyone because I took
one abnormal site class. Haha, I'm the king of psychology.
I'm sorry. I just I can't. These people are deeply unserious.
Okay, wait. Do you have this one? Oh god,
so many people. Stop or don't you know what? Don't stop. I say
stop. Do not stop DMing me funny airite clips. Okay, we'll just
watch all of them. What is this?
What is this? Chloe, remember when I gave you that $400 dono
and you said that you'd wear those nice shoes and then you never
sent me those shoes and when you wore those shoes they were knockoffs
and it made me very mad because I wanted this nice shoes and
beat off my wiener two and I gave you $400. Chloe, you're a chameleon.
You're fake. You hate men, Chloe. You hate them. You hate them.
Even though you're called a pick me even though your entire channel
is about throwing other women under the bus. It's not enough.
It's not enough. I want better only fans. That's act that that
that's the actual energy of this.
I'm an empath. I know what's going on in people's minds. I'm
I've done two years of psychology. I can mind reading people.
I know what's going on. I bet you everyone has autism because
I'm going to diagnose everyone because I took one abnormal site
class. I'm the king of psychology. If only Twitch wasn't crashing
on me for no reason, that would have been awesome. Okay, that
would have been [__] awesome.
>> Twitch just just crashing on me for no reason. God damn
it.